my biggest problem with the yeah the
videos is quality of quantity and stuff
yeah if it's quantity i get too bored
because i'm not challenging myself and
this quality i take too damn long i'd be
so scared to take one month and just
know that like it could not do well i
know i know you know i cry like every
time i i upload a video i [ __ ] i'm
like
i'm dead i'm like
i just i cry i don't actually cry but
i'm just like i'm sad for like two days
why and then but i pick myself up
even if it does well yep
because like when you first release it
you're like what if nobody watches it
right right and you you wonder that for
like
whatever but for some reason animation
it's like trinkling views it's like yeah
with animation it's definitely more like
you know it picks up really quickly over
a long period of time yeah long period
of time where it's like a lot of like
flesh tubing videos it's like
less tube video not flesh tubing
that was weird
but with a lot of like fleshtube videos
like like me and connor's like
yeah it's like usually it's like within
the first week or something it's like
majority of the views and then maybe
every now and then it'll like kind of
pick up you know in the long run some
videos just like don't stop getting
views yeah but i'd say like you know i'd
say i don't know about in your case but
like most videos it's like the first
week is like yeah yeah yeah for sure
yeah yeah occasionally you just get like
one video that just seems to like defy
like oh
yeah yeah is this so funny because like
sometimes like conor will be like oh
this video didn't perform well he gets
like sad i'm like bro you only took like
a week to make that [ __ ]
well sometimes i'll take like two months
to make one video there's some videos
that have taken me like months and
there's ones that take me five minutes
yeah yeah yeah it's like the dichotomy
is like shocking at times yeah he's not
going to be like that with the video he
took five minutes yeah what we can what
we could share together is that the
[ __ ] youtube studios is
pure pain
why is it in the front just hide that
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i
completely agree it should not be front
and center
like like yeah just like
they remove dislikes and then they keep
the [ __ ] one actual thing that is
like actual detrimental to my mental
health front and center like everyone i
don't know a single person that likes
that feature like i i i'm fine with it
if you have to dig for it yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
exactly
why is it in the very front page why is
it when i just want to see how my video
is doing that's the first thing i have
to see like i'm forced to see it you
know and it's like oh you're you're [ __ ]
and then
you're [ __ ] today oh yeah
it's just such because i guess if you
upload a video that doesn't do well for
one whole month you've got to look at it
yeah yeah you get you get sad and you're
like
oh man
yeah yeah yeah
it's
scary i like kind of like intermittently
just like remove the app entirely from
my phone especially if it's like a video
that's like you know like a nine out of
ten or something i was like i don't want
to [ __ ] look at this yeah all right
so i just like remove it from my phone
until my next video yeah yeah if it does
well then i see the fireworks i was like
all right installing that [ __ ] again
baby yeah
well as well but you're like well i like
this video i'm gonna upload it yeah
people aren't gonna watch it yeah or i
know that youtube's gonna like kill it
yeah yeah yeah yeah uh animators or
whatever i don't know what you call them
i don't like being called something
because story time people no because you
call the story time it's like the
community is like
or like v i'm a be tuber and then you
get tech by the v tuber community it's
like when you have i think that's just
like any community
this community in general the word
community is always toxic no matter what
yeah
i'm just like i'm an artist yeah i just
i'm just an artist i don't know
but like i've noticed like a lot of
story time animators are like yeah
they've
they they don't
they they don't post it anymore actually
like a lot of them yeah they're they're
all burnt out it's such a burnt they're
burning out kind of well they're like
kind of doing other stuff like twitch
and you know i mean i get it because
switch is like it's like feeding it if
you're if you're on every day you're a
big boom right and you're on a trend
that's like absolutely crushing it and
then suddenly you and all your peers are
like making half the money and yeah you
have to put yeah you put in like double
the time yeah yeah
what like half the money half of you
like trip all the time and then it's
like and then it's like all right well
what are we
why am i doing this yeah yeah so like a
lot of the story times are trying to
like pivot yeah yeah yeah i'm trying to
pivot a little bit just to have like
faster like feasible like content
yeah because i think like especially you
know
with storytime youtubers because it
takes so much work
um and you it's impossible to like not
make not spend a month on this video and
pour your [ __ ] heart and soul into it
you know yeah like you have no life it
yeah yeah yeah three weeks of no lifeing
i would say yes and that and that's like
a lot to invest emotionally if your
video is not going to perform well
yeah yeah yeah like uh you know you put
three weeks of work in you get like a
thousand bucks you're like
well that's why we we we try to take
like any sponsor if we can we're like
right right yeah yeah because i mean if
you if you did three works of three
weeks worth of work in a very
specialized industry yeah and they gave
you a thousand bucks for like doing like
i'm gonna be honest i would i would i
would probably quit by now if i didn't
get sponsors i was like it is it's like
it's not worth it but i hate when people
are like oh because you don't you don't
you're not doing it for the art it's
like [ __ ] no yeah i'm trying to pay rent
like yeah yeah easy enough to say that
when you live with your parents right
yeah in the start it was yeah it was
like yeah i'm doing this because it's
hard because i love doing it and i i
still do it
yeah yeah yeah yeah i do enjoy doing it
but the thing is i i enjoy doing it but
if i can't pay rent with it i can't yeah
yeah yeah yeah like i gotta go and get a
job and then i'll upload once every
night and it's not even that nice my man
like it's not even that nowadays either
it's like you know you it's like i also
need to pay my [ __ ] editor i need a
pair of people who help me in shoots you
know yeah it's not just me anymore yeah
it's it's annoying too because like for
some reason like uh live actioners that
they get a they get flesh
flush tuber yeah they get a password
when they do sponsors and then when like
animators do it it's just like
really what happened to the passion
really really
not anymore it usually used to i think
that used to be like everyone yeah
everyone it's like if your sponsor
wasn't like directly involved with your
content yeah yeah yeah yeah like oh he's
such a [ __ ] seller like i remember
like i remember when patreon yeah i
remember when patreon first launched and
like anyone who got a patreon was just
like wow i can't believe you sold out my
god you think i'm going to [ __ ]
donate to you
stop e-begging your [ __ ] like
they called it e-begging and it was and
i was just like it's it's it's nice that
the mentality has completely changed
over time to now be like oh this video's
not going to sponsor yo you you you
playing run okay bro you know like like
like sponsors are like completely normal
now um and now nowadays thank god
like a sponsored video there'd always be
that comment being like damn joey
getting that bread today yeah yeah yeah
yeah encouraging about it yeah yeah yeah
yeah
five years ago
not nothing like that no no no no no
even five years it was like three years
ago yeah like couple years ago i was
like nothing like that was around so
it's like it's just so weird now that
it's almost like i don't know
congratulated in a sense or like i i
think it's just more becoming more
accepted that being a youtuber is a job
and uh not just a job but a career you
know
we'd require sponsors in order to keep
the show running and i think people have
now
more accepted that youtube is one of the
main forms of entertainment that a lot
of people watch it's like i think now
the the majority of the understanding is
that
a youtuber getting sponsored means that
there's going to be better quality [ __ ]
because i think because it's gone up
sometimes yeah sometimes you know like
you know i think they just want the
money yeah sometimes they just want the
money of course but like i think the
general understanding is like oh they're
going to use this money to like up their
quality or like their content in
whatever way right yeah
well like the first job of being a
youtuber is making it sustainable and
making it like making it so you can
support yourself and a lot of the times
you can't support yourself without a
patreon or without sponsors you know
there are some forms of content like
animators which have like which you guys
have a much harder time generating
revenue when you upload once a month
yeah well why didn't you why didn't any
of the i never really saw any of the
storytelling people getting patreons i
never really saw it much that's the
thing like most i guess animators for
most artists they hate making money
because it makes them feel bad because
like
it's like oh i'm selling out to the
devil like my passion
and i'm like i used to be like that
right yeah but then like lately i'm like
bro i can't i can't do this
doesn't pay the bills
it's just like it's just nice it's like
bro but even like passion doesn't get
you through those hard days where you're
just like i don't want to work today man
but i gotta upload something like we had
to like draw a line yeah yeah sometimes
i'm
[Music]
[Music]